so one of the main concerns here is uh
something called AI takeoff
or a fast takeoff that the exponential
Improvement would be really fast to
where like in days in days yeah
um I mean
there's this isn't this is a pretty
serious at least to me it's become more
of a serious concern
just how amazing Chad GPT turned out to
be and then the Improvement of gbt4
almost like to where it surprised
everyone seemingly you can correct me
including you so gpd4 has not surprised
me at all in terms of the reception
there chat GPT surprised us a little bit
but I still was like advocating we'd do
it because I thought it was going to do
really great yeah um so like you know
maybe I thought it would have been like
the 10th fastest growing product in
history and not the number one fastest
they're like okay you know I think it's
like hard you should never kind of
assume Something's Gonna Be Like the
most successful product launch ever
um but we thought it was at least many
of us thought it was going to be really
good
gvt4 has weirdly not been that much of
an update for most people you know
they're like oh it's better than 3.5 but
I thought it was going to be better than
3.5 and it's cool but you know this is
like
someone said to me over the weekend
you shipped an AGI and I somehow like
I'm just going about my daily life and
I'm not that impressed
and I obviously don't think we shipped
an AGI
um but I get the point and the world is
continuing on
when you build or somebody Builds an
artificial general intelligence would
that be fast or slow would we
know what's happening or not
would we go about our day on the weekend
or not so I'll come back to the would we
go about our day or not thing I think
there's like a bunch of interesting
lessons from kovid and the UFO videos
and a whole bunch of other stuff that we
can talk to there but on the takeoff
question if we imagine a two by two
Matrix of short timelines till AGI
starts long timelines till AGI starts
slow take off fast takeoff
do you have an instinct on what do you
think the safest quadrant would be so uh
the different options are less next year
yeah say the takeoff that we start the
takeoff period yeah next year or in 20
years 20 years and then it takes
one year or 10 years well you can even
say one year or five years whatever you
want
the takeoff I feel like now
is uh is safer
so do I so I'm in longer no I'm in these
slow
take off short timelines is the most
likely good world and we optimize the
company to
have Maximum Impact in that world to try
to push for that kind of a world
and the decisions that we make are
you know there's like probability masses
but weighted towards that
and I think
I'm very afraid of the fast takeoffs
I think in the longer timelines it's
harder to have a slow take off there's a
bunch of other problems too
um but that's what we're trying to do do
you think gpt4 is an AGI
I think if it is
just like with the UFO videos
uh we wouldn't know immediately
I think it's actually hard to know that
when I've been thinking I was playing
with GPT for
and thinking how would I know if it's an
AGI or not because I think in terms of
uh to put it in a different way
um how much of AGI is the interface I
have with the thing
and how much of it uh is the actual
wisdom inside of it like uh part of me
thinks that you could have a model
that's capable of super intelligence
and uh it just hasn't been quite
unlocked this is what I saw with Chad
GPT just doing that little bit of Ro
with human feedback makes the thing
somehow much more impressive much more
usable so maybe if you have a few more
tricks like you said there's like
hundreds of Tricks inside open AI a few
more tricks and also in holy